[Music]
the U.S accidentally dropped two nuclear
bombs on North Carolina when a transport
plane broke apart in midair one nuke was
found and according to Secretary of
Defense McNamara it was only by the
slightest margin of chance literally the
failure of two wires to cross that it
didn't explode the second plunged into a
muddy field when retrieval efforts came
up short they decided to leave the
uranium core underground the Army
purchased a 400-foot circular easement
over the components prohibiting building
in the area and this is only one of the
six nuclear weapons the U.S military has
lost since 1950. yes this really
happened